The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So the
question is, we have
the string s is the string 600
is 6 triple 1 and 6 triple 2.
So we're going to
create the string here.
It's initially an empty string.
I want to mention that the
plus equals-- for example,
if I say a plus equals 1.
This is equivalent to
a is equal to a plus 1.
We've seen this a couple of
times before-- last lecture
and the last
lecture before that.
So all this means
here, this line here,
is we're going to take the
previous string that we have,
and we're just going
to add it to itself,
plus the last letter.
So the first thing we're going
to have is going to be new_str
is equal to 2.
Then this line here is
going to say now I'm
going to add to the two
that I already have,
the element at position
0, which is a 6.
So I'm going to have 6.
Then I'm going to add to
that, the element at index 4.
So I'm starting count from 0.
So this is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So that's a space.
And I'm going to go--
notice I have 4, and then
nothing in the middle.
So my stop is going to
be length s by default.
And I'm going to take
every 30 characters.
Now every 30 is longer than
the actual string I have.
So we're just going to end
at the end of the string.
So the next thing that we're
going to add is a space.
And then the last
thing we're doing here
is we're starting at 13.
So now I'm going to have to
count 13-- 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
That's the 1.
I'm going to go backward,
because of this minus 1.
And I'm going to go
backward until 10, but right
before 10-- so 1 less than 10.
So I'm going to do 100.
So this one, this
0, and then this 0.
Then I'm going to
print this new string.
I think this is right.
If you paste it into Spider, it
should give you 26 space 100.
So I think most of the
class got it right.
I think, yes.
Perfect.